[Music]
transformers 4 you are going to see but
wait his transfer at one through three
that's a six-hour job kids don't need to
come in I'll catch you up in two minutes
Oh
Autobots Megatron Decepticons yellow
robot aliens fighting on Cybertron is so
weird cute thing Decepticons wanna use
to kill everything and Megatron when the
g1 Earth but crash lands they can remand
[ __ ] the cube and I'm super damn
years later Mikaela is the crush of Sam
Witwicky
oh and also Sam's car get the cubed
Megatron back in the government you
better leave might be gone but we'll be
signals for the Autobots in distress
who's gonna get to the cube Master is a
race to the dam and Sam gets the cue
button freed up from attitude it's under
Miss Brown vs. Megatron dude
screw the samples the cube in Megatron's
chest which I guess this persecute and
Megatron supplement this isn't over but
I guess we'll see then Sam and Mikayla
make out I'm bumblebee transformers too
many years ago transformers harvested
arms the Fallen is a jerk chicken
Earth's only wall the harvester thing I
think you called the matrix kind of
present day the fallens back cardstock
piece of the cube it's Dillon same shirt
it resurrects Megatron now someone's
gonna get hurt someone is optimistic
mega-truck you timid who's the next
target
am Megatron Sam he's almost not alive in
a dream sandwiches are the matrix and
guess what another time three-way the
bond and Megatron our subscribers gonna
win in two finishes rhyme the fall
another Megatron escape of course you
know they can't just let it end up more
used to go
transformers 3 New York spacecraft has a
thing to stop the robot bites crashed on
the moon with sentinel prime
out-of-sight years later preference
ensign on his predecessor plus Cruiser
making space bridge for transporting
better Sam figures are intercepted
customers really bad the Autobots are
personally there should be close we'll
take off but they think they're death to
show Decepticons are huge German snipers
everyone but the Autobots destroy the
feeler enzyme before they're done it's
killing sensible and mega jumper Autobot
earth is from now on
now you can watch for
[Music]